I love it when a plan comes together
word Smiths because the word I'm
featuring in this video is strategic
strategic it's an adjective and it means
related to a plan it's the adjective
form of strategy uh which is a way of
thinking about making effective and
successful plans or the plan itself
strategic comes from Greek the word
Stratos means general as in the
commander of an army being strategic
means you're thinking like a general
Commander troops like you're trying to
play five games of Chess at once the ick
part the IC part is an adjective forming
suffix so it turns nouns into modifiers
into adjectives so strategic means like
a
general what do you see from these word
Parts what do you see in strateg and I
I'll give you 10 seconds to come up with
similar words throw in a little music
here we
go
[Music]
here's what I came up with there's
strategy which is like a trick or a
cunning little plan that you pull off in
other words a
maneuver Cosmic which means it has to do
with outer space right it's the the word
Cosmos plus I the adjective forming
suffix Cosmos is outer space strategize
which is the verb form of strategic or
strategy it means to make plans to come
up with a strategy okay troops follow me
over to the next screen where we'll use
strategic in a few sentences haa if
you're strategic with your chocolate
chip placement you can use cookies to
spell words this one appears to say con
if you're if you're clever about it if
you thought through the plan and its
implications if you're strategic you can
create cookie Mischief which is probably
one of the 10 best kinds of Mischief
okay let's try it as a noun now as
strategy after three straight days of
failure the scientists decided to
attempt a new strategy what was that
strategy I don't know I didn't read
their lab notes and it kind of appears
as if those lab notes have gone into the
trash but here's what I do know you can
learn anything wordsmiths David out